in front of me is three random Minecraft
players in front of the three of you is
a red button when you press the red
button you're either gonna get a
challenge or win a hundred thousand
dollars oh my God what who wants to
press the red button first ladies first
ladies first come on you got a challenge
you cannot press the button again until
you destroy every single block on this
house have fun okay be strategic with
your TNT okay okay I have a thousand
blocks that's so much effort okay I'm
going to go on I'm going find the
diamond your challenge is you have a
giant stone block and inside's only one
Diamond I got this i got this where is
it I'm finding this diamond Marquee go
ahead hit it you don't have to wait on
me okay get in second okay bet you're
probably thinking this is a normal
chicken right yeah it has to be right
then why is it name totally not a normal
chicken with a thousand Health get the
killing go go go oh my God it's so quick
too stop running
oh my God nice let's go whoa Grady
already finished his ah that seems
messed up this is actually kind of a
tough challenge one of the other guys
only had to kill a chicken
so Grady you can press the button again
or you can just wait for other people to
press it I'm pressing it reach the
ground
so we have proximity chat I want you to
yell as you fall okay
100 Grand on say uh lifetime supply of
orange
Grady fell from a high place what is
Grady doing oh my gosh there's so much
health left this chicken needs to stop I
don't know if you know this but we
probably gave you a sword in a chest
somewhere what you know maybe right
beside the car oh okay thank you uh
beautiful now I can enjoy my steak
[Music]
yeah how was blowing up the house it was
really fun let's see if dying five
different ways is just as fun I'm really
good at dying in Minecraft it's okay
I've never seen somebody so excited to
just die can you punch me
I'm gonna go to the other room
all right good luck Gracie
no I keep seeing the notification that
you fell bro why do you suck this bad
it's going horrible okay we got this we
got this I believe I believe
oh you did it
you have to go touch grass in real life
be right back take a picture
what are you doing now I'm lowering my
health so that it takes less time to die
from Fall damage how many ways have you
died this is my last one
like that go go go go go go
I don't have
to have this oh man this is gonna take
forever okay I'll give you a little Pat
in the back all right I'll see you later
okay okay I got grass I touched grass I
touched grass oh nice beard
touch a cloud okay I can do this I've
touched many clouds clouds are pretty
high I hope you know that just gonna get
as many blocks of this as I can like if
I don't have enough we're just screw it
I think anyways how's beating up the
chicken going it's running around I'm
almost
few more hits oh your chicken's running
away
yes there we go that took me forever but
maybe it might all be worth it because
this will probably be a hundred thousand
dollars okay okay okay press the right
button oh my god well this might take
some time I will say it's one of the
buttons in this room okay good luck are
you still trying to break this Jimmy I
think she needs a pad on the back for
motivation
was there
what if I destroyed this block
there's a second obsidian I don't have
the
SE
you want to give me a pickaxe
yeah I'll go get one I'll be right back
four minutes oh oh this one okay halfway
there
I think we have enough I think we have
enough to get there go go go go go go go
go go go go go
yes go go go go go go go go go go go go
this might be the hundred thousand
dollars right here please
solve the maze oh my God you know what
sometimes good things Don't Come Easy
Grady what does this remind you of ah it
reminds me of my childhood you tell me
it doesn't remind you of offer GX the
greatest browser on the planet
unlike other boring web browsers Opera
GX offers tons of customization with GX
mods a free one-click way to make
browsing fun they even made a mod
specifically inspired by me it has a
live wallpaper that reacts to your mouse
and evolves the background based on
where you move it whoa you're making
progress dude what the heck we're going
baby and Opera GX makes it incredibly
easy to import all your settings from
your current browser there's no reason
to not switch simply go to this URL
right here or click the one in the
description and install the Opera GX
browser right now there's even the 12
latest Mr Beast gaming videos at the top
so you never miss one of our newest
uploads what well not only that Grady
since you're doing the challenge during
the ad read Opera GX wanted me to give
you a fire gaming laptop oh project of
you once you finish the maze I mean
technically someone can win the
underground while you're doing it please
don't do me dirty thanks George to our
sponsor Opera GX
you've done the most challenges but is
that gonna result in a hundred thousand
this is messed up
hatch a chicken that shouldn't be hard
I'm sure you just have to wait for them
to lay an egg all right have fun Carl
let's go harass other people okay thanks
oh my God you're so close
this makes
my sister you got this
wait this could be it this is the one
second treasure I think maybe I just
need to swim down I think that's what it
is
oh my God what is this bro just find the
sunken treasure there's no way I need to
fight this like now don't forget only
100 Grands on the line Jimmy it's not
helping
and I'm done with the walls and I gotta
run around and do the same thing
honestly you should probably just quit
is 100 Grand really worth all this
trouble yes it is yes and you've pressed
over a thousand buttons just so you know
feels great I'm gonna be here for ages
you suck at this this is taking so long
what if the first one lays an egg and
it's no chicken I have a 12.5 chance
that's bad I know
but I really I just don't know
what are you looking for some buried
treasure wait
wait
I can't believe I missed that
hit the creeper across son of a bee
sting uh okay I gotta get the creeper
across what's this button do oh hey
buddy we probably have to like let it
use a Nate
oh boy I'm just gonna come visit that's
it we're just going on a little walk
just a little walk together Grady what
are you doing well I'm gonna get a
creeper across here how's it going for
you I'm waiting for what is this go lay
your eggs I
I lay eggs I have none of the eggs
hatches chicken oh egg you are a good
look you should stay here you should
stay here oh there you go was it your
first egg it was what it was the first
one so this has nothing to do with you
but uh buttons surrounded by obsidian no
good luck
this is it though this is the Run
oh you're good we're good
those clothes do you have more pressure
when I'm here a little bit a little bit
a little bit a little bit
oh you're almost done
[Music]
obsidian so you guys could uh you know
catch up with each other hey Grady hey
Gracie
there's a party at the button hurry up
okay okay okay okay okay okay
come on
oh my God okay I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go so I will be honest we are over
halfway done let's go what do you might
actually end up winning the 100 Grand
with this next set of presses oh my gosh
this is nerve-wracking who's gonna press
it next got it not it do I press it yeah
find the blue flower have fun I hate
everything but oh my god oh no that
looks like a man that didn't want 100
G's oh what is this place with the oh
where's the blue flower man oh my God
this is tough the next button press
should be the 100 grand
the roller coaster oh no
this is like the slowest roller coaster
of all time do you have any
all right good luck
this is the worst now Marquee you don't
have to press it you can just wait I'm
gonna send it I'm gonna send it I'm
gonna send it I'm gonna send it I'm just
going with it I'm gonna go with it fine
Nemo Nemo I will find you we do a little
bit of fishing do you know the odds of
catching Nemo is it like 10 or something
you're close it's two percent what okay
okay I got this i got this i got this i
got this dude I have to focus so hard to
even just see anything at all do your
eyes not work not right now apparently
like I could have already seen it and
then like now but the point of this one
is to waste your time while someone wins
100 Grand how could you oh the blue
flower later man this sucks
all of my challenges have been patience
like testing and I have a really short
attention span well you're almost
halfway there it's better than a third
of the way Nemo no a bone okay well it
didn't look like Nemo at all I'm gonna
be honest you think I can catch the Nemo
before yeah yes this could be it Marquee
you could be a thousand air okay okay
okay
no what is my luck today come on wait
what is this puzzle oh my God no way
wait oh I can break them I need to find
my Corners I should probably place them
first
[Music]
um
I mean the figure goes crazy I like the
chain in the shirt and everything
yes Sparky you've been given some of the
most difficult challenges I'll give you
an Insight it's not the next button
press I could trust you because he did
give me a sword on the chicken challenge
and hello here you guys want to come
help Grady find a blue flower yeah yeah
let's see what he's up to hey Grady oh
my God grace all the way out there you
go
there goes the blue flower searching
going now that you guys are here it
feels good man it feels really good he
might not finish this challenge before
you guys win Grady you've walked past
like 30 times you're like there's no way
there's no way
wait
oh I'm so bad I'm so bad and now we all
three meet again we're getting scarily
close to the end be very very careful
I'm just gonna send it put three shirts
on I won't be able to hear you for a
second so you got shirts to put on man
all right Marky or Gracie
100 jumping jacks all right
do you think this next press is 100 G's
I think it's an IRL challenge we use the
flag I don't have to do jumping jacks or
put any shirts on I'm good here's my
strategy for this one I'm gonna try to
Purl onto the walls and then from the
walls I'm gonna pull on the platforms oh
no I should have thrown it higher
next works the spot if I was an ex that
marked the spot where would I be
I love how she's doing it right by the
button too so we have to hear
is not prepared you have to try to get
to the lever that sounds like a hard
challenge have fun favorite force it
this is hilarious this is on purpose
totally
we're making progress you just finished
this out you're almost done
please where is this thing oh I have a
freaking treasure map oh my gosh two
palm trees with the rock and a small one
it's like right here somewhere
let's go I really want that hundred
thousand dollars Grady the hundred
thousand dollar decision is coming up do
you press it now or do you wait till
after someone presses it oh my gosh oh
or never press the button again you're
gonna watch this video Grady and if you
don't win 100 G's you're gonna be like
dang I didn't want 100 G's here's been
my Strat the whole time I've hit the
button first because you know what
somebody has to take initiative and is
it gonna be me okay okay we're almost
there we're almost there I got a method
okay this is looking good there's
nothing I can't do I'm gonna do it
so close oh my God you just won a
hundred thousand dollars I almost
convinced you to skip it too you almost
did oh my god dude and Gracie I'm Mark
don't worry we're gonna give you two
oh my God goodbye